The joe rogan experience,
like everything in you is telling you,
dawn,
this is a bad idea and then your kid's sick over the next year.
I think it's very easy just psychologically it'd be like,
well that's what fucking happened when I gave him to that guy and he fucking
prick them.
That's the reason my son is in circumcise was because he was born at three in
the morning and they were going to do it the next day and when I brought,
I had held him,
I loved him.
I looked at him in the face if they were going to do it right away,
like take them like cut them.
Don't give a fuck.
I don't want to have a weird dead,
but now we did a point.
He hit anyway.
Boy squeezed at the beginning to up.
She took the kids head up.
Look at the top off when you squeeze your pussy,
all you want to do with that pussy squeeze,
squeeze,
squeeze.
Either what?
My son's fucking head.
You can't help it.
You whore.
You gotta squeeze it tight.
Fucking rampid hanging out.
Did they came back the next day.
They're like,
are we going to take him now?
And I mean I'd,
I mean I had fucking hung out with him.
He's my son.
I loved him at that point so much.
So I take them to a strip club already.
Chicken also implanted in my mind,
all of these babies,
circumcision videos where she made me watch.
And it's a fluffer thing,
dude.
Yeah,
it's terrible.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a barbaric practice that people only do because it was done to them.
And because we feel like it's part of tradition and I agree they have these
bullshit stories.
Abella Ooh,
help or you try vue test shut up
that they did that.
They did a study in Africa where they took like a few hundred people in like a
fucking straight up a place in Africa where it was like one out of every four
people had aids and they proved that circumcising them was stopping the
transmission of aids because there's not as many breaks in the forest scan.
So it was not as easy to transmit the disease.
But we were talking about a third world country where they're not cleaning their
bodies.
We don't live in that same type of poverty or or fucked up like disease.
Yeah.
If you look at any of the justifications for circumcision,
they're all super weak and none of them actually,
you know,
they'll say these things where it's like,
well you can't get cancer and you're forced scan or something like that and
you're like,
yeah,
and if you just lopped off chicks breasts,
they can't get breast cancer,
but we're still not going to just preemptively be like,
let's just fucking start castrating people,
I don't know.
I got to tell you,
it changes the sensitivity of your Dick.
Dick supposed to start slippery at the top.
Meanwhile you pull that force going away.
It just dries up like an old piece of gum.
It's not supposed to be like that.
We've lived with literally change with Dick's feel like when they go into
people's bodies it is gross.
When you describe it a an uncircumcised Dick is self lubricating.
That's what it is.
That's how they got the business done back in the day.
It is a,
but that's the way my Dick Hangs soft.
I could,
I would hate having four skin.
I think you'd get over it.
Just that would you rather that or no deck that are no deck for get new force
came back or no Dick.
Oh,
of course.
Yeah.
Right,
so just let it go.
If you should accept a check that's two extreme ends of the rainbow.
That's where I live.
I still to try and take it back.
I don't know if I can go back now and just say,
all right,
what?
I just take my,
if genie came out the gay ass,
Jeanie on her came in and said we're going to have one wish and it's just about
your foresee.
I'm pretty specific.
Wishes it back.
Let's see what's up.
You want to know is he cut again?
If you're a crazy ass hole,
well they also want to do it and least then it would be your decision
reconstructive surgery they have for it to the whole shit.
I've seen what they do.
They take clothes pins and they pull your dick apart the
waist down,
stretch the skin out around your dick and it becomes kind of like a force hurt
turtleneck for skin.
Like instead of like being one piece of meat,
it's like a double piece of rolled up
like ghost face killer.
It's like when Webster was hanging in his closet to try to make himself taller.
All the gross.
Your shit about four skin is accentuated by the fact that it's a double.
It's a,
it's essentially like the whole skin of the deck has to go over the top of the
deck.
Yeah,
it's outrageous.
They get a pen.
Tell teller bullshit about that.
Easy.
There's so into it,
but here's the thing we should do and congratulations to you for doing that.
Don't circumcise your kids anymore.
It's crazy.
You got to stop something really weird and fucked up.
It's dangerous.
It's not a hundred percent dangerous,
but it might be one out of a thousand kids get some sort of an infection and
they could lose their deck.
That happens and then they do a sexual reassignment surgery.
That's a regular thing that we're not,
you know,
when it happens,
they fuck up their dicks,
a circumcision.
They get the infection and then they say,
all right,
well now you can have a baby with no dick and then have it be a boy or we can
sexual sexually reassign it to be a girl.
And kids find out years later that they were born a boy.
And that's why that happened.
That's actually a famous case.
There's a famous case about that where they did a botched circumcision.
The kids penis was removed and then they decided to give him a sexual
reassignment and everyone was fucking terrified of it.
It didn't work.
The kid became massively,
massively depressed and then wind up committing suicide,
uh,
as an adult and just just felt robbed of reality.
You know,
by what,
by some crazy,
stupid avoidable ritual where you're going to cut baby Dick's cause you think it
looks better.
And,
and in the best case scenario,
even when all that shit doesn't happen,
you're torturing a baby.
Yeah.
I mean how else could you describe it?
They are not using novacane but not like numb older.
The local like you're not,
but if anyone,
if you ever had a surgery like that and they were like,
oh,
we're just gonna put some local that,
I mean like no one does gang.
So bad.
You're so sensitive.
You don't even know what pain is.
Your little tiny one day old person.
What someone's and your Dick already like.
What kind of a world of I've been fucking does to you in that moment where
you're like,
we don't know the type of psychological damage that that causes in that moment,
this real intense pain.
They in the world,
they want their mom,
they want to be helping us,
her mom's breasts,
they want to be feeding with their mom.
They want the love right now.
That's what they're supposed to get.
And you take them and you fucking mutilate them.
Who knows what type of switch you turn on in that fucking babies head in that
moment.
Yeah.
You make Jewish people.
Yeah,
start all the wars.
So there you go.
They decided to fucking really good,
good at finance and the diamond business and
they were like one of the first people to be circumstances like that.
It's like if Jewish people you always assume were circumcised,
right?
Yeah.
Like why is that?
It's just part of that,
but there's no way.
No one really knows.
Any reason.
We're trying to save a little,
you know,
the most horrific you ever watched the circumcision rituals they do in Africa.
It have seen a few,
oh my God,
this is a video of this dude just standing there,
standing there,
balls ass naked and the guy comes over,
grabs his dick,
grabs us with one swipe of the blade,
shoots,
takes off the force,
can pulls on his dick and slices away and yanked it off and the guy stands there
completely.
Stone face doesn't react and that's like part of the ritual is Dana White
Wilson.
So you want to be an ultimate fighter.
His Dick is bleeding and he's just staying there.
He's not looking at it and it's not a good circumcision cut either.
It's totally fucked.
It's like peeling an orange.
Right?
You never got to get a straight line.
It's really what it looks like at this poor guy's Dick.
It's it's so if you see the Jamie,
do you know the video?
There's also the saved in my phone as the Jewish,
a ceremony where the Rabat isn't the rabbi like suck blood or something that's a
dick.
Yeah,
like every,
it's not that every Jew doesn't do that,
but there's
Dick sucked by a rabbi.
I might've,
heavy baby sick Dick Sucking call crabbers version.
I brought this up three years ago on the show and I'm the only person doing any
research on our show.
I may seem like I'm the dumbest one,
but I promise you right now you're the most prepared,
dumbest ones.
I'm the one doing the research.
I brought this up and everyone looked at me like I'm an Asshole,
and I'm like,
no,
I swear to God,
rabbis are at,
they're stuck babies decks and you guys were videos of them justifying it.
You gave a really crazy thing because they had to,
there was some serious problems with it.
Oddly enough because of herpes,
because babies were getting herpes and dying from herpes,
from rabbi sucking their Dick after they performed this circumcision.
And apparently in some versions of Judaism it's,
it's a part of the ritual and that this guy was explaining it and like in,
in Yiddish,
and he was explaining all the different things that what's important that the
rabbi or the who have the Moalel performs this.
I think you'd said it like to tsetse he had like a word for it.
Oh,
you mean the bowls he's at?
He's a nice old word for suck baby Dick's.
You just cut.
I mean it's so the only in religion,
do you have a youtube video where you're dressed like a wizard talking about
sucking baby Dixie just cut and,
well this is the part of our tradition.
But do you think [inaudible] argument,
like you're not just in some fucking like,
like dress and like making it like singing some song.
You're actually going like,
well this is why I have to do,
have you seen it?
Do you think it's definitely sinister?
No,
it's retarded always.
Or was it just like,
it's fucking stupid.
They're stuck in it and someone did it to him and someone did it to his dad and
they feel like they're a part of this clan.
It's fucking,
and you feel like if you were to give up on that,
you're giving up on your dad family.
Everything's alive.
So you got to just blindly believe that this is what you did
in retards progress.
It is the eating literally as retarded,
like in that sense,
like forget about the derogatory term he used for people.
It's a retarded idea.
It retards logic.
You cutting a baby dick and socking on it,
then you're making a youtube video saying,
well,
but when we thought the world was flat,
this is how we do it.
We were still doing it this way and we like to cut it and we like to stock.
I think we have a name for it.
It's a noise that I make with my mouth that's different than sucking cut baby
daddy.
I'll judge.
It's very important.
A rose by any other name I say.
Yeah.
I mean it was crazy that someone could sit around and justify doing some shit to
a baby's Dick just because they've always done it.
But I,
I think all of it to have Jackie Mason to it,
like
a reasonable rate.
It's just a little quick.
I got to cut it off.
Look,
I mean as if it's any better to cut it and not suck it.
Like at least maybe it feels better for the kid to us.
We're just going to stick.
If the kid standpoint,
you would definitely want somebody to suck your Dick after you got to cut.
But how,
what kind of a person just sucks baby decks all the time.
Like how many baby eve took an average rabbi that's done this or [inaudible] but
it was it a more oil,
oil,
oil more was Manuel.
So like a shoe company or something that's close to him.
Oh,
well,
but these how many baby dicks in a lifetime and a strong career?
35 year career working for the synagogue.
How many baby?
Dick's,
if you some numbers.
Imagine.
Did he go to college and Arizona?
Does that matter particularly slutty rabbi,
could you imagine if she has to fight like a Nazi and Nuremberg?
He goes,
I was following orders.
I think it was a website and like you just see like it just scrolled and you
know that bar and the right side.
The dot was really tiny to see new.
There's a lot of scrolling to do.
It's all the baby dexi sucked over the years.
I kept it album,
but will those are guy you told me it was the best.
Check out my Instagram image.
My name is
Jamie.
Do not show us that son of a bitch.
Check.
How's that online?
Is that on Youtube?
There's blood everywhere.
There's,
they cut it.
There's blood everywhere in the baby's screaming and the guy sucks the baby's
deck.
Congratulations.
You're an idiot.
Sorry for cutting your Dick though.
This is one of those things that because it's a part of a religion,
people get mad if you'd take it down.
People get mad if you shit on it,
but this is one of the Co.
If you see there's no clear indication that your religion has gone completely
off the track,
that if you're cutting baby Dick's and then sucking them,
anybody in their right mind outside of that religion and saying,
we didn't do the Charlie thinking about cutting the baby digs and sucking them.
What exactly?
MTI and the CIA.
Here's what's fucked up.
That's on youtube.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah,
there's a lot of Jewish people that are watching their families getting their
dicks cut and then suck.
But then there's also a whole sector of pedophile vampires that are watching
that and just beating off to it all day long.
Dude,
some fucking guy who taught his dog to Heil Hitler and he's looking at jail
time,
but you could suck a baby's Dick on youtube and your fucking video just go up.
Yes,
Baby Dick's,
but I want to go to jail.
Hmm.
Oh,
become a rabbi.
I don't know.
No,
Yeah.
Let me get that down to show you.
There's a bunch of them.
There's hundreds of them.
Hundreds of guys suck and baby dicks,
and it's 2018 this is not a Jewish religion.
We're not living in the barbarian times,
but today people are cutting in suck in baby Dick's.
How about genital female genital mutilation for it?
How Much Zach?
For two please.
Can you say that anymore,
man?
Yes,
you can march.
It's march.
Oh wait.
Oh,
it's a female as of April.
It's off.
[inaudible]
okay.